une nouvelle étude du professeur gilles
eric séralini révélé aujourd'hui le
chercheur de l'université de caen
démontre que la nourriture des rats
utilisés pour les tests sur les ogm
contient déjà une forte dose de
pesticides
bonjour professeur vous êtes en duplex
avec en jeu depuis paris en fait vous
dénoncer le fait que l'ump fabriquant
des ogm et des pesticides utilisent des
produits sanitairement polluants pour
fausser les tests c'est ça c'est tout à
fait ça en fait nous avons fait rentrer
la nourriture de cinq continents
j'utilise notamment les industriels pour
tester non seulement effectivement les
pesticides et les ogm mais aussi tous
les produits chimiques de notre société
quand ils sont testés à long terme et
les médicaments et nous nous sommes
rendu compte que cette nourriture
étaient contaminés à des taux qui donne
des risques 40 sur une échelle où il
faut se préoccuper à partir de 1,2 et il
y à des taux de pcb de dioxine de
pesticides de gm et de métaux lourds qui
peuvent expliquer à eux seuls des
maladies chroniques
alors les industriels se targuait que
bien les rats avaient naturellement
jusqu'à 90% de tumeurs hypophysaires ou
71% tumeur mammaire ce que ne trouvions
pas dans nos études et que on considère
comme complètement anormal alors on a
creusé plus loin on a voulu savoir
quelle nourriture ils utilisaient et
même dans un test sur un ogm il
utilisait dans leurs témoins des
nourritures qui pouvait expliquer des
maladies dont il ne tenait pas compte
parce qu'il voyait la même chose dans
les témoins alors vous avez aujourd'hui
vous êtes entendus quand même vous êtes
entendus quand même puisque ségolène
royal on le rappelle viens d'essayer
d'interdire l'utilisation chez les
particuliers du round up un désherbant
chimique est un peu le symbole de ce
contre quoi vous combattez depuis une
dizaine d'années ensuite c'est quoi
l'interdiction totale du roundup et des
produits qui comprennent du glyphosate
qui est une substance cancérogène c'est
ça alors effectivement on se réjouit de
ce type de décision
il manque encore beaucoup de choses par
exemple on permet à travers les ogm
importé aux citoyens de manger beaucoup
de résidus drame dap et donc il devrait
y avoir aussi un moratoire là dessus
puisque 80% des ogm contiennent du
roundup et mais on ne l'interdît pas
pour les agriculteurs qui ont beaucoup
de méthodes alternatives
et puis il faudrait faire ça dans le
monde vous savez que plos one la revue
qui nous publier et qui nous publie a eu
des pressions en tout cas je pose
officiellement la question parce qu'elle
a retardé la parution de notre article
pour des raisons mineurs nous a posé des
questions qui sont tout à fait mineurs
et vous savez que nous avons été
victimes d'un industriel qui est
évidemment faisait des pressions sur les
journaux scientifiques dans lesquelles
nous publions nous sommes coutumiers du
fait et cela évite les polémiques par
exemple aux états unis les agences de
presse ne vont pas s'emparer de cet
article qu'elle était prête à relayer à
cause de cela
donc on a un vrai problème et ce que
nous demandons c'est la transparence sur
les tests qui ont servi à autoriser tous
ces produits
parce que ça ça ne va coûter 0 euros aux
citoyens aux industriels et il considère
aujourd'hui que tous ces tests sont
confidentielles ainsi on pourra savoir
quelle nourriture ils utilisent et
comment ils ont sous-estimé les maladies
parce qu'ils avaient les mêmes dans les
rats contrôle où les ratés - merci
beaucoup professeur séralini d'avoir
accepté notre invitation à propos de
cette nouvelle étude donc que vous
publiez merci à vous